Sie wird immer länger – die Schlange vor
dieser Corona-Schwerpunkt-Praxis in Berlin.
Getestet wird direkt am Fenster –
ohne, dass man vorher in einem
Wartezimmer sitzen
oder einen Termin ausmachen muss.
Es ist wirklich eine gute Option, und es dauert
nicht so lange.
Es ist vielleicht auch ein bisschen sicherer,
als in einem Krankenhaus in einem engen
Raum zu sitzen
mit anderen kranken Patienten.
Hier tragen alle Maske, und getestet wird nur
durch das Fenster.
Es ist wirklich gut.
Allgemeinmedizinerin Sibylle Katzenstein
leitet die Praxis.
Sie bereitet sich auf einen harten
Corona-Winter vor –
mit noch viel mehr Patienten.
Also, ich will den Teufel nicht an die Wand
malen.
Aber ich bin… also die Zahlen
steigen ganz eindeutig, ja.
Also, man will ja auf jeden Fall
den Lockdown verhindern,
man will verhindern, dass die Schulen
schließen.
Das heißt, wir müssen wir uns irgendwie so
durch den Winter quälen. Ja.
Um sich darauf vorzubereiten, will
Deutschland
zusätzlich sogenannte Fieberambulanzen
eröffnen.
Sie sollen nur Menschen mit
Erkältungssymptomen behandeln.
Außerdem wurde den Gesundheitsämtern
mehr Personal versprochen,
um Infektionsketten besser nachverfolgen zu
können.
Die Stärkung der Gesundheitsämter,
die politisch angekündigt
und versprochen wurde,
ist ausgerichtet auf die nächsten fünf Jahre.
Da sollen 5000 neue Stellen geschaffen
werden.
Das heißt aber: Jetzt im Oktober und im
November
haben wir diese Stellen noch gar nicht in den
Gesundheitsämtern,
und damit haben wir natürlich noch ein
Problem,
was wir jetzt akut erstmal lösen müssen.
Doch statt nur auf Fieberambulanzen und
Gesundheitsämter zu setzen,
möchte Sibylle Katzenstein den Patienten
lieber Tests zu Hause ermöglichen.
Sie müssen die Möglichkeit an die Hand
kriegen,
dass das arztunabhängig …
die Testung möglich ist,
also dass man in die Apotheke geht
und sich seinen Test holt.
Und auch wenn das jetzt nicht
hundertprozentig sensitiv und spezifisch ist,
dann ist das doch ein sehr guter Indikator, der
eigentlich reicht, epidemiologisch gesehen.
Der sogenannte Antigen-Test ist ein
Abstrich-Test.
Das Ergebnis wird innerhalb von 15 Minuten
angezeigt - ganz ohne Labor.
In Deutschland können ihn zurzeit allerdings
nur Ärzte und Apotheker bestellen.
Sollte die Zahl der Corona-Fälle
im Winter steigen,
könnte es auch eine Freigabe für alle geben.